Hola Qué tal Buenas tardes Bueno aquí me
encuentro frente a la sede de Madres de
Plaza de Mayo se hace viejo algunas de
las madres entrando a gente cercana a la
organización también este sería el
corazón de La despedida más cercana
también vos mencionabas La despedida del
presidente Alberto Fernández una que fue
muy temprana en su saludo y su despedida
de bueno finni fue la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner con un
tweet temprano en la mañana de hecho yo
me enteré por el tweet de Cristina
Fernández que la saludaba a nivel
internacional también apareció en
despedidas de gente cercana a ella
Nicolás Maduro Rafael Correa Evo Morales
estamos hablando de personajes de la
izquierda latinoamericana Con quienes
estaba muy vinculada y por eso cuando
hablabas de La despedida en Argentina yo
quería decir que también era una figura
muy polarizante en esta en este momento
en los últimos años la debe de bonafini
en Argentina y no todos tienen la misma
relación con su figura a pesar de que en
origen era alguien que se había vuelto
profundamente representativo de ese
proceso de democratización y de lucha
por los Derechos Humanos en el país Cuál
es el legado que deja Eve de bonafini
Bueno eso es Interesante como te
comentaba hay una cosa doble pensemos
que es una señora que a sus 49 años en
el año 77 era ama de casa en la
provincia de Buenos Aires y se encontró
con la realidad de que la dictadura
había secuestrado y hecho desaparecer a
sus dos hijos varones a partir de
Entonces se juntó con otras mujeres en
su misma situación y conformó lo que fue
Madres de Plaza de Mayo con esas
primeras marchas en la Plaza de Mayo muy
muy valientes en pedido en pedido por el
paradero de sus hijos se consolidó como
una figura importante de los Derechos
Humanos en el país también a nivel
mundial luego también empezó a tomar
posiciones a veces un poco más radicales
profundamente ante imperialistas anti
neoliberales de defensa muchas veces de
regímenes cuestionados en la región
regímenes de izquierda y eso ha generado
que su figura se haya vuelto una figura
muchas veces criticada en el país a la
vez que respetada yo creo que conviven
esas dos eves de bonafin en el recuerdo
de Argentina pero no se puede negar que
ha sido una figura central en la
historia de Argentina de los últimos 45
años